Unreal's animation editor isn't a single tool, but a collection of the following five different tools.
There is the animation blueprint editor, the skeletal mesh editor, the skeleton editor, the animation editor, and the physics editor.
And each one of these tools plays a different role when it comes to dealing with animations.
So let's pop over to the editor now and take a look at this.
So inside the editor, I'm going to hit Control Space to bring up my content browser.
For my filters, I'm going to click on Skeletal Mesh and I'm going to bring up this tentacle right here.
And notice as soon as I do that, we are brought into the Skeleton tool, or I should say, I'm sorry, the Skeletal Mesh Editor.
From here, we can do things like assign our materials, adjust our LODs, as well as adjust many of the various properties like skin weights, import settings, and things like that.
We also have our Skeleton Editor.
The Skeleton Editor allows us to adjust the skeleton or the rig that was brought in with this.
From here, we can right click and we can copy bone names or add sockets or add virtual bones and other things of that nature.
This right here opens up our Animation Editor.
The Animation Editor allows us to add notifies or adjust various properties that have been assigned to our animations.
Next to that, we have our Animation Blueprint.
Animation Blueprints are very powerful as they allow you to combine the power of animation and blueprints to do things like set up state machines or have your animations wait for particular input in order to fire off some other type of animation logic.
Last but not least, we have the Physics Authoring tool or the FAT Editor.
This tool right here is used to create the physics bodies that will be used whenever this is used in some types of physics simulation.